Ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo
video a grande richiesta torna il traduttore di maryna oggi in particolare ci occuperemo di
ragazzi ebbene sì cari ragazzi siete
spacciati perché grazie a questa innovativa tecnologia
tutte le ragazze da casa potranno finalmente
capire che cosa volete dire quando dite
queste frasi per adesso non sono pronto per una storia seria
scusami non gli piaci abbastanza
amore senti ti da fastidio se esco
voglio uscire apprezza che ti stia chiedendo umilmente il permesso ma va amore sará una serata tranquilla tra amici
discoteca fino all'alba
ma ti pare che la sento ancora
la sento ancora la sento ancora
amore quale mi metto
ma non lo so quello nero per me un vestito vale l'altro
basta che tu ti dia una mossa si decidi tu dove andare a cena per me va bene tutto
davvero scegli tu il ristorante tanto qualsiasi cosa ti proponga non ti va mai bene ma amore è maryna la youtuber
la seguo perché fanno ridere I suoi video anzi guardali anche te che cosa stai aspettando
iscriviti anche tu al canale di maryna e clicca sulla campanella per ricevere le notifiche san valentino è proprio una festa inutile
non ho la più pallida idea di cosa regalarti amore ma ti pare non le ho mica guardato il culo
non le ho guardato il sedere le ho proprio fatto la radiografia
é solo un'amica tranquilla
ovviamente non è solo un'amica
amore vado a cena con i miei amici tutti maschi
in realtà non sono certo che a cena saremo solo maschi ma se ti dico che
potrebbero esserci anche delle ragazze tu non mi faresti uscire quindi
siamo solo ragazzi amore ma quello corto nero quello lungo fucsia ma quello che vuoi tanto sai che sei sempre bella
datti una mossa ho fame stasera fa la brava mi raccomando non fare la...
cretina
ti giuro che non so chi sia deve avermi chiesto l'amicizia anni fa glie l'ho chiesta io dopo ben tre giorni di stalking e
ovviamente perché me la volevo non è che non mi piaci
é che ti vedo solo come un' amica
non mi piaci la m che ho tatuato é per mamma ma è anche per maryna era destino che ci incontrassimo
é l'iniziale della mia ex
la mia ex ma chi la sente più quella in realtà ogni tanto la sento ovviamente in amicizia
però non te lo posso dire perché se te lo dicessi
scoppierebbe la terza guerra mondiale prendi pure cellulare non troverai nulla di compromettente
ho già provveduto ad eliminare tutto il materiale compromettente quindi prego guarda pure
amore ci sentiamo dopo che devo fare una cosa non mi scrivere per almeno tre ore
amore devo dirti una cosa ma promettimi che non ti arrabbi so già che ti incazzerai
amore ti giuro che non è come sembra
è come sembra
forse anche peggio
no no tranquilla non ho niente
sono incazzato nero ma se i social neanche li uso dai
li uso li uso ho anche tre profili fake per stalkerare meglio le mie ex
Non sono abbastanza per te meriti di meglio davvero non sei abbastanza per me merito di meglio
guarda che non ho per forza bisogno di uscire con qualcuno
qualità non quantità sì certo
basta che respiri ma te l'ho detto avevo il telefono scarico non avevo voglia di risponderti
quindi sali da me
non pensar male non sono mica quel tipo di ragazzo sono esattamente quel tipo di ragazzo
piacere mi piaci però sei una bellissima ragazza ma non voglio niente di serio
non mi piaci abbastanza
e l'altra sera ero completamente
ubriaco mi serve una pausa il problema sono io e non tu
il problema sei tu si ok va bene come vuoi tu dai
non ho voglia di discutere ti va di salire da me a vedere un film
Ci siamo capiti
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del video spero vivamente che questo video vi possa tornare utile in diverse situazioni
fatemi sapere con un commentino qui sotto quali di queste frasi avete sentito più spesso e soprattutto
ricordatevi di seguirmi su tutti gli altri social facebook instagram e tiktok io vi mando un bacio e ci vediamo al prossimo
video adoro